The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, everyone.
Welcome back.
Today we're going to
talk about the profiling
tools available on Cell
to help you evaluate
how your programs are running.
In the next hour
I'll talk about SIMD,
which is how you can take
advantage of the hardware
support for data
parallelization.
First up, I'd like to follow
up with some questions
that we had last time
about gdb, and then I'll
discuss some of the various
methods for profiling on Cell.
I'll talk about
the Cell simulator
and using the decrementers,
and then we're
going to talk about static
profiling and instruction
reordering, which I started
to get into last time.
So first up, we ran
into some problems
last time with gdb,
various error messages.
First thing,
sometimes gbd is going
to examine the wrong
variable, as we saw
when the names are ambiguous.
One thing you can
do to get around
this-- we had problems
with ambiguity
between variables, which have
the same name where one of them
was in the spu thread and one
of them was in the ppu thread.
And so to work around
this, one thing you can do
is use spu-gdb, which will
just log on to a particular spu
thread, then you can just
look for variable names
in that thread.
You can also, of course,
rename your variables.
Second problem is
that sometimes gdb
will delete your
breakpoints before you
want it to delete them.
Reason being, it will
remove breakpoints
whenever the program
associated with a breakpoint
has been unloaded.
But sometimes you have
more than one thread
running the same program,
and so the second one you
won't be able to break into.
So again, you can use spu-gdb
to log on to a particular thread
if you want to do that.
Another thing you can do is
for example put a delay loop
at the end of your
spu thread in order
to keep that thread running
for as long as possible.
It seems that as long as gdb
doesn't unload that thread,
then it won't delete
your breakpoint.
And finally, I saw this kind
of cryptic error thread event
breakpoint gdb should not stop.
Indeed it shouldn't.
One thing, to get
around this, it
seems that this problem
doesn't happen on spu-gdb.
So I'll just recap how to use
spu-gdb to debug your programs.
Last time we were
using mostly ppu-gdb,
which will help you debug
kind of both your PPU program
and your SPU program together.
And you're able to switch
between all the threads
that are available.
On the other hand, when
you're using spu-gdb,
it's just going to log on
to a particular SPU thread.
So what you do is you invoke
your original people PPU
program with SPU
debug star equals 1.
And then you can background it.
Now what happens is every
time that your-- every time
that your SPU-- sorry, every
time that your program spawns
a new SPU thread, it
will print the process ID
and then actually that
thread, the spawned thread,
will stop and wait for a
debugger to attach to it.
So at this point, you can run
spu-gdb -p and then the process
number that they give you.
And when you attach to it,
you can continue that thread
to resume debugging.
Any questions?
OK, so the Cell simulator
is one of the tools
that we have available
to help you debug.
This is how you invoke it
if you have it installed,
opt/ibm/systemsim
cell/bin/systemsim,
and you want to use -g to
use the graphical interface.
And a little window will
pop up and you'll click Go.
The window looks like this.
It actually, from
here, you can have
a lot of fine-grained
control over how
your program is running.
In fact you can advance the
state of the simulation cycle
by cycle to look at what's going
on inside the simulated Cell
system.
And when you boot
up this simulator,
you can actually get a complete
Linux environment in there
with an x term.
And what you can do in
this Linux environment is
you can copy over programs
and then you can--
you can copy over programs which
were compiled for the Cell,
and then you can run them.
In order to transfer a program
to your simulated system
so that you can run it,
you can use this function--
or you can use this
program call through which
is available on the
simulated system.
And what it will
do is it will grab
onto a file which is on the
host system and copy it in.
And it will just
put it on standard
out so you can redirect it
to whatever file you want.
And then when you
make it executable,
then you can run it.
All right, questions?
While you're in
the simulator, you
can view a lot of
different things.
You can get a lot of information
about the state of the machine.
In particular, you can
look at the registers
at any particular time, again
with clock step by clock step.
This might not be as interesting
now that you have the debugger.
And you can run the
debugger on real hardware.
But one thing which
the Cell simulator does
get you is these
dynamic profiling tools.
And what it will
do is it will look
at the state of the simulation
and it will figure out
where things are stalling,
where the time is
being spent by the processor.
And you can get separate
stats like these.
Let's see, it tells you, for
example, total cycle count
stalls for various reasons.
You get all these
statistics separately
for the PPU and each SPU.
So this can be very helpful
if you're trying to do,
for example, you're
trying to figure out
exactly what's
going on each SPU,
do load balancing, whatever.
And so these
statistics will hold--
these statistics will cover
whatever length of the program
you run.
But you can also get more
fine-grain statistics
using these profiling functions.
So if you include profile
dot H in your program,
then you get access
to these functions,
profile clear, start, and stop.
And what these will
do is they actually--
when they get compiled
into your program,
there are no ops when you run
them on a real Cell processor.
But the simulator will be
able to latch onto them
and you can use those to start
and stop regions of interest
for profiling.
Now the simulator
comes with the SDK,
and it's a little bit
cumbersome to install.
So we haven't made it available
yet on the actual PS3 hardware.
You can run it on x86, and so
if your group would like to get
set up with that on
one of your computers,
or we'll try and make it
available on our hardware
if there's enough interest.
So please let us know.
OK, the next thing we'll
cover is using decrementers
to profile your program.
This is one way you can use
dynamic profiling, which
actually doesn't
require the simulator.
So when you get information
from the decrementers,
you can run these programs
on your actual Cell hardware.
Basically the
decrementer is just
a counter that counts
down at a constant rate.
So you can use it as
a clock to figure out
how long different
events are lasting.
And the rate at which the
decrementer counts down
is not that fast.
So you're not going to be
able to use it to time things
on the order of a
few clock cycles.
It's best for
timing things which
are maybe on the
order of thousands
of instructions in length.
And how you use it is there
are these SPU write channel
and SPU read channel
functions which
give you access to some of
the internals of the Cell
processor.
And so here's an example
setup you can use.
Basically, first you
call write channel,
and you pass in this
MFC_DECREMENTER_EVENT thing.
And what that will do is
initialize this decrementer
counter for you.
And then you read the value
before and after the function
you want to profile,
and when you subtract,
that just gives you the length
or the time that was elapsed
in some arbitrary units.
And of course,
it's counting down,
so you want to subtract
the start from the end.
And after you're
done using it, you
can do another write
channel to stop
the counter from continuing.
All right, any questions?
OK, let's continue talking about
instruction reordering, which
I started last time.
So I'm going to kind of start
from the beginning this time,
and maybe it'll
be more coherent.
So on the Cell
architecture, when
you're looking at what
instructions are being run,
the instructions are mostly
going to be of the form
evaluate some function
of some of the registers
and write the result
to some other register.
And the assembly
file are what you
get when you run
with GCC-S is just
going to be a human-readable
representation
of these instructions.
And I'll show you how to
read that actually later.
And you can think of
these instructions
just as executing in series
just in the order in which they
appear in the assembly.
So if you think of one
instruction starting and then
finishing, the next
instruction comes in,
finishes, that should be
consistent with the actual
behavior of the hardware.
Now for real hardware,
waiting for one instruction
to finish before the next one
starts is going to be too slow.
So there are these various
optimizations we pull
or that they do on
the hardware in order
to run instructions sooner than
when the previous instruction
finishes.
So the big one of
these is pipelining,
where you have multiple
stages inside your processor,
and you can run
each instruction--
you can push each instruction
in before the previous one has
completed.
And in pipelining,
you're going to be
subject to these dependencies
between instructions.
For example, if one
instruction reads from a value
that the previous
instruction wrote, then
clearly you can't start
the second instruction
until after the first
instruction has completed.
The Cell processor also has--
actually has multiple pipelines
in which you can
insert instructions
and another
optimization that they
do is branch prediction
in order to reduce stalls
from branching.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Can you talk about
static branch prediction?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so static
branch prediction means--
or, rather the way
it's done on the Cell
is that what's
predicted for the branch
is not going to be affected by
the history of which branches
have been taken.
And some other
processors actually
do use this information.
All right, now the
thing about pipelining
is that because we
still have to honor
these dependencies
between instructions,
the order in which we
evaluate instructions,
that's going to make a
difference on how long
the program runs.
So let's take the
simple example where
we have three
instructions, a, b, and c,
and we have this
pipeline processor where
we can insert instructions
at these clock ticks.
So suppose that c
depends on b, and there
are no other dependencies
in the system.
Then this sequence
of instructions
is going to take five
cycles, because we
can push b in after
the first cycle,
but we can't push c in
until two cycles after that.
Is that clear?
Questions?
All right, now because
c depends on b,
it kind of makes sense to
push b as far up as we can in
order to ease this dependency.
So if we execute b before
a instead of after a--
and remember we can
reorder b and a however
we want because there's no
dependencies between them--
then we can start b at the first
tick, then we put in a right
after that, and then c.
And now the sequence only
takes four clock cycles.
All right?
So observe that, when we put
in c in this third clock cycle,
we actually couldn't have
put in the third instruction
any sooner, no matter what
the dependencies were.
And so in general,
we're going to want
that to be the case where
we want instructions
to be waiting on the pipeline
rather than on dependencies.
So that means in
the first picture
there's this stall
of one clock cycle,
and we're going to
want to eliminate
these kinds of stalls.
All right?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to use these static
profiling tools to figure out
where stalls happen.
Now the first thing we're going
to do-- the first thing that we
have to do is generate the
assembly and the instruction
schedule that goes with it.
And so you can use GCC -S, and
the same flag works with xlc
to generate the assembly.
And then we have this
utility called spu_timing,
which runs on the Cell,
and which will tell you
the instruction schedule.
Basically it'll take
in your assembly file
and tell you exactly when each
instruction in that assembly
gets scheduled.
If you call it with
-running-count,
then it'll tell you the
running count of clock cycles
at each stage,
which means if you
look at the last number,
that will tell you
how long your program took
to run in clock cycles.
And we'll write the
output to a file
with the same name as the input
but with dot timing at the end.
Now if you're
using our Makefile,
you can actually do all
this, generate the assembly
and the timing info, all in
one step by doing SPU_TIMING=1
and then make the name of
the .s file, all right?
Now if you'll
recall on Cell we're
going to have only
in-order execution.
The instructions are just
going to execute in the order
that they're specified
in the assembly.
And because the Cell
has dual pipelines,
that means there's two pipelines
in which instructions can go,
and the pipelines are
going to be selected just
based on the instruction type.
And of course, two
instructions are only
going to go in simultaneously
when the dependencies allow it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if you're looking
at the assembly,
you're going to see lots
of lines of this form OP
DESTINATION and then
the source registers.
So when you're trying to
figure out dependencies,
it's going to be helpful
to be able to look
at each line of the
assembly and figure out
what registers that
line is reading from,
and what registers that
line is spreading to.
And there's also information
in the assembly file
I went into that last
time, which tells you
kind of for each
chunk of assembly what
the corresponding
source file line is.
All right, and the actual
output of the static profiler,
like I said, it will
spit out a schedule
of when each instruction runs.
And in the schedule,
you're going
to see one digit for each
cycle that the instruction is
running.
So however many
digits there are,
that's how many
cycles are being used.
And in front of some
of the instructions,
you're going to see these
dashes which represent stalls.
So these three dashes in
front of this instruction fm
means that based
on the pipeline,
you could've scheduled
this instruction up here
right after the previous
instruction finished.
However, because you're waiting
on particular dependencies,
you're only going to
be able to schedule it
these three cycles later.
So that's a three cycle stall.
And the static
profile output is also
going to show other information.
The original assembly appears
on the right-hand side.
And which pipeline the
instructions are going into
is going to show up on the left.
Any questions about this format?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Dual-issue just
means that these instructions
are going to be executed
at the same time.
AUDIENCE: So can
people figure out,
for example, what is the
latency for fm instruction?
How many circles does fm take?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: What are the
numbers on the right?
PROFESSOR: Over here?
All right, so these
are the arguments
to the assembly instructions.
So remember the first one is
going to be the destination
register and the other ones
are going to be all the source
registers that that
instruction is going to use.
All right, so
again, we want to be
able to reorder these
instructions to minimize
stalls.
And what you're
going to do is you're
going to try and look
for instructions that
are going to take a long time
potentially, for example, loads
and floating point instructions
are going to take a long time.
And of these instructions
have dependencies
then those dependencies
are going to stall.
So not only do you want
to minimize stalls,
you also want to dual issue
instructions whenever possible,
although that's a little
bit more difficult to just
kind of eyeball.
But anyway, if you get up to
the ideal running point, where
you're able to dual issue every
instruction, then that means
you're going to be running
two instructions per cycle,
or it's going to take 1/2
cycle per instruction.
Anyway, going through
these assembly files,
and figuring out where
the dependencies are,
which instructions you can move
around, it's kind of tedious,
and you're not going to be
able to apply these techniques
to your entire program.
So if you only
have limited time,
what you're going
to have to do is
try these on the most
critical code first.
And that's usually
going to be loop bodies,
because those are going to
get executed many, many times.
And any savings
that you see there
will be multiplied
many, many times over.
So I'm going to go
through an example
of one possible
optimization you could do.
So we'll actually go
through these same files
in the exercise about
two minutes from now.
This is from Lab 1.
And this is one of
the code snippets
or the assembly snippets
from the SPU program.
So notice that over
here we have these load
instructions followed
by a, I guess
this is a shift instruction.
And there's two pairs of these.
And in each one, the
shift instruction
is going to depend on the
result of the previous load.
Does everyone see that
from the arguments?
So now the problem is that
because the shift is happening
right after the load, it's
going to stall for a long time,
because the load
takes six cycles.
All right, so what
can we do over here
in order to reduce stalling?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Two
loads concurrently?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we can
do the loads concurrently,
and in general, we just
want to move these loads up
as high as we can.
So if I move the two loads
up to the top of this--
oops-- the top of
this snippet, then we
have two loads followed
by all the instructions
that came after.
Now the first shift is going
to stall by only two cycles,
and the second shift is
not going to stall at all.
All right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So, pardon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the question is
what would this change look
like in code?
The thing is that
kind of the order
of these generate
instructions is
going to be dependent
on the compiler,
and it's really
up to the compiler
how it wants to order
these instructions.
So this change is
not going to be
reflected in like your C code.
And that's why you have
to do these optimizations
after the assembly is generated.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If you
have a smart compiler
then it might do some kind
of instruction scheduling
in order to minimize stalls
using this methodology.
Yup?
AUDIENCE: I'm quite
impressed with XLC.
I compiled the same
program under GCC
for SPU with optimization
level 3 under XLC.
XLC ran in half the time.
So it was doing a much better
job of instruction scheduling--
AUDIENCE: Than GCC?
AUDIENCE: Than GCC.
So that's something,
if you've got a choice,
and the XLC compiler
is working for you--
AUDIENCE: In general, this kind
of sort of low-level assembly
hacking for instruction ordering
is not something you'll do,
just because
compilers are getting
incredibly good at doing
instruction scheduling.
But here the exercise is for
you to sort of get familiar
with the tools and
understand a little bit more
in detail as to what's
going on at the instruction
level [INAUDIBLE] pipelines.
Another thing to
note here is, well,
two things you could
consider here, how high up
can you push the limits?
And related to that is, why
can't you completely hide
the latency for the first load,
and hence the first shift still
takes two seconds to stall.
So that's dependent
upon how much slack
do you have in your schedule,
dependent on dependencies
and where the loops starts.
So in some cases,
you just simply
can't hide the entire latency.
So it's part of considerations
you have to consider.
But [INAUDIBLE]
and the compilers
are getting really good at it.
PROFESSOR: And in
case you're wondering,
I think this code
was compiled using
XLC on no
optimizations, which is
why there's this really easy
opportunity for optimization
here.
It turns out, if we run
the timing utility again,
we saved eight cycles.
So notice that on
the previous picture,
we're going up to
seven in that column.
And now we're only going up to
the previous nine, all right?
So what we're going to do for
the exercise right now is you
can try something like this.
What we're going to try and
do is just improve performance
by rescheduling instructions.
And so if you
download the tarball,
you'll get the exact same
file I was working on before.
And what we're going to
have you do is just generate
the assembly, practice
generating the assembly,
modifying it, and then
continuing with the rest of the
build process to
get a new object
file that's based on
your modified assembly.
All right, any questions?
Now you just need to find,
for example, one opportunity
for optimization.
And you can do the exact same
thing that I did, if you want.
And so the key is just after
you've done your reordering,
you want to re-run
the timing utility
to see how many
cycles you saved.
Also you want to, of course,
continue the build process
to get the final
executable file.
And you want to run that just
to make sure that your code is
still correct.
AUDIENCE: Are we
able to get this?
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: OK, so this
static profiling process does
have its limitations.
The first is that, and this
is a pretty major limitation,
the static profiler assumes that
none of the branches are taken.
So basically it just zips
through the entire assembly
file in a straight line.
So that means you're
going to have a skewed
view of how long code inside
conditionals or loop bodies is
going to take, because
conditionals, if there's
savings in there, they
may not run at all.
And loop bodies,
any savings in there
may get multiplied
many, many times.
So if, for example,
you see that you've
saved eight cycles in
the static scheduling,
you're going to need to
know some more context, that
is whether it's
inside a loop body
and how many times you
expect that to run.
So you're going to need
a little more information
to get a good idea of how these
instruction reorderings are
actually affecting the
runtime of your program.
And also, because this is
static profiling, which
means you're not using an
actual program run to get data,
you're not going
to get behavior--
you're not going to capture
any behavior that depends
on the inputs to your program.
So for example, you don't
get counts of how many times
each loop runs, or when
each branch is taken.
One other thing to
worry about, which
isn't going to be manifested
in these static profiling
predictions, is
branch prediction.
Now remember the
static profiler is just
going to ignore all branches.
And the thing is that
branch prediction,
because branch
prediction is used
to reduce the stall
after a branch is taken
by kind of pre-fetching
instructions
and possibly doing other things.
So what we'll do is
guess the direction
that the branch will take.
And then we'll start
pre-fetching instructions
from the expected
place where it's going
to resume after the branch.
And the thing is, if your
branch prediction is wrong,
then you're going to incur
a pretty large penalty.
And the penalty is on
the order of 20 cycles
while it flushes the
pipeline and starts
fetching instructions
from the new place.
On the other hand, if branch
prediction is correct,
then there's no penalty
at all, actually.
So the next
instruction will just
resume right after the branch.
Anyway, you can give
hints to the compiler
to tell it what you think the
outcomes of branches will be.
And this can help in
some circumstances.
Basically there are these
macros that you can define.
And what you're going to use is
this built-in expect compiler
intrinsic, and
what that means is
if you put that inside
an if, it will mean,
you know, run the if as
if the condition were exp.
But then I'm going to
expect that the value
of this condition is going to
be, for example, true or false.
All right, does that make sense?
Anyway, just one note about
the exercise that you did.
I believe the original run
time was 469 clock cycles.
Actually, if you run XLC
with 05 optimizations,
it will reduce that to 188, so
almost 280 cycles of savings.
All right, so we'll-- pardon?
AUDIENCE: The one that
we just [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, so the
original code was--
the original assembly
was compiled on O 0,
or no optimizations.
But then if you're doing
an optimization by hand,
it saves eight
cycles off of O 0.
These are actually
pretty easy to find.
And the 05 optimization level
will actually shave off 280
cycles.
So we'll break for
about 10 minutes,
and then after the break,
we'll do SIMD on Cell.